sir sure
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
dumps dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
[Music]
[Music]
big massive dump you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water rushes
out to seed
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
gums
[Music]
what is going on here
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
mangoes my bag of mangoes up under trump
cost me eight dollars i love mangoes too
nine cents okay
now that we are up under avoidance
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
my bag of mangoes my bag
my bag of mangoes my bag
my bag of mangoes my bad
my bag of mangoes bring my mangoes back
down
[Music]
that seems like a pretty good deal
aren't mangoes like three bucks each
[Music]
they want to go out and they want to
touch they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
[Music]
yesterday we had three big ones really
big suppression balls you don't give me
the umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly
so you say to your wife you said your
husband darling let's go out to dinner
and then we'll come back we love our
president but you know the polls say he
can't win well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leaving
well i'm soaking wet already suppression
balls
red wave
i'm soaking wet already suppression
balls
suppression balls
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat
kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're common
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank
for you if you are under the age senator
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
there is so much about what comes out of
donald trump's mouth don't be rude that
is designed to distract the american
people
from what he is doing every day that is
about neglect negligence and harmony you
are fake news
and in the midst of this public health
pandemic
we have a donald trump
he knew the deal about colvin
he had been informed
that it can kill people that it is five
times as likely to kill as the flu he
knew it was airborne
he knew it could harm children
[Music]
all right welcome everybody what an
evening we have for us today
we are moments away
from the first results in the 2021
california gubernatorial recall election
we are monitoring multiple streams
streams of consciousness streams of
video all sorts of streams
and um in about um 85 minutes
the poles will fully close they're going
to be fully the body is going to shut
them completely down
uh we we are actually going to be able
to hit the body supposing we hit the
body with a tremendous uh very powerful
light
right we're going to be doing that to
the ballots
we will be looking for barbecue sauce
bamboo fibers green onion everything the
the the ballots will be looked at
very closely
and we will have a sense i believe
i believe we will have a sense of who is
going to
uh be governor in california
within about an hour and a half i
actually you know uh we obviously have
to be very careful and in fact let's
look at the latest polling
when we were in this area august 3 4 5 6
7
nine ten it was a tie
and my feeling was i don't know if
enough californians are paying attention
to what's going on yet
so everybody's gotta vote
and then the lead started to open just a
little bit for gavin newsom
and it has now swelled
to a what is that 15.8 percent lead so
i have been very cautious
i believe that gavin newsom
is going to absolutely crush this thing
now this is aside from is it too easy to
even get a recall going in california i
believe the answer is yes
i believe the answer is yes
yes but
for today
i want to crush these people
larry elder
could not be
a worse choice there i don't i can't
think of a worse choice for california
than larry elder it's tough
maybe jesse lee peterson right uh maybe
maybe trump i don't know everything
you're doing is wrong right she hung up
yeah
so um i re i i want to crush these
people and i hope that the numbers are
uh i hope the numbers uh uh back that up
and the the numbers make it a reality
now
we will be joined at the top of the hour
by i i don't know exactly but one of
the leading democratic alternatives to
gavin newsom in this thing uh kevin
paffrath youtuber and realtor
um he will be joining us at the top of
the hour
okay so if people want to hear from him
he will be here if people don't want to
hear from him he will be here
in either case he is going to be here so
that's going on
later today
um and what else do we have here
the numbers coming in in about an hour
and 23 minutes all right everybody so
everybody relax we've got a little bit
of time
i can't tell you how glad i am to see
all of you here i didn't know how much
interest there was going to be in this
but people are here welcome welcome uh
we have
will i be talking about the aoc dress
i will and you know why
because today she's wearing a different
dress helping us to promote our coupon
code no recall we have a coupon code
today
aoc uh modeling the dress no recall is
the coupon code because we want no
recall no recall today all right this is
uh that is the name of the game and oh
hold on a second
gotta zoom this in let's see there is
the code no recall discount code okay
now honestly i really don't care about
the dress it's like famous people get
invited to stuff with other famous
people
she makes a fine salary
but she had student loans she's not like
uber wealthy right now
and she showed up and she said tax the
rich on her dress i just really don't
care that much i really don't i don't
know how else to say it it's fine i'm
much more appreciative that today she's
helping to promote the discount code
okay
that's what i'm glad about today so i
really don't know that a bunch of people
wrote to me and said david talk about
the dress
i'm just struggling because i really
don't care but she'll be here to help us
promote the coupon code it is no recall
at joinedpakman.com and everybody is
going to be thanked okay what do we have
going on here we have cbs news live we
have abc news about ready to go we are
monitoring nbc news
we also are waiting for right-wing
streams the count the right side
broadcasting network is going to
apparently be interviewing larry elder
uh and
we also have newsmax now let's look at
exit polls okay
um do we have them here where are the
exit polls
oh wait someone said fox news released
them let's take a look at the exit polls
uh allow ads no i'm not not right now
not unless you're gonna force me to
where are the exit polls
i actually don't see them here
anybody know where we can find them
california recall exit polls
oh here it is yeah okay oh okay i did
look at this before i'm gonna get to
super chats momentarily okay guys uh
momentarily
okay
um all right
covet pandemic remains at the top of
voters minds one-third says that was the
biggest issue that's a plurality i think
that that's very bad for larry elder who
said he will end all mass mandates and
all vaccine mandates and requirements
that's followed by one-fifth saying
homelessness my instinct is the
homelessness people
want knew some out
but it's only one-fifth covered by far
bigger issue one in six say the economy
and wildfires slightly under one-tenth
say crime
concerns vary among partisan lines more
than four in ten dems say it's coveted
only one-fifth of republicans say the
same on the flip side republicans are
more than three times as likely as
democrats to name the economy as their
top concern
voters have mixed outlooks on the
pandemics course
four intents say the situation's getting
better three say it remains the same one
quarter say that it is worsening
under half of the electorate 45 percent
say newsome's policies on the pandemic
have been about right one-third call his
policies too strict the remain
remainders say they are not strict
enough
uh six and ten say getting vaccinated is
more of a public health responsibility
than a personal choice i don't think
that's good for elder who was running on
i will end every requirement
um
yeah i i gotta tell you i don't think
this looks good at all
at all for larry elder
and i really hope that this guy gets
crushed crushed crushed crushed
all right let's kick things off with
some super chats
um
david awesome to have a stream like this
on a tuesday night absolutely daniel
says i heard california was trying out a
novel ballot curing method similar to
what is done with mortadella yeah yeah
you know in spain actually as many of
you know i don't eat pork
and in spain a couple weeks ago
i had a beautiful beef-based
i would call it a charcuterie
called cecina
and
i read that they are actually applying
the same curing methods you you
basically are applying
quite frankly you're applying light and
heat to cure apply
light and heat to cure they're applying
the same curing methods as i had with my
cecina in spain
to the california ballots and even spicy
olive oils apparently um in play as i
would say matt wilson sending an
incredibly generous 50 dollar super chat
i appreciate that matt biggest super
chat we've had in a while
mindhax asks from the standpoint of
doing
how are you that's a great question one
of the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water i'm doing well glad
to be here on a tuesday
bronx bjorn says this is a win for
republicans either way because it sets
up the narrative that dems are
undemocratic cheaters
no i actually disagree
i don't think anybody but the most
extreme lunatic republicans who already
believe it about the november election
are going to believe that tonight's
election was rigged larry elder is
already saying it was rigged we don't
even have the results yet but i actually
don't agree with that i think this is
going to be i think if if newsom crushes
tonight it's a bad omen for trumpism
because this is in a sense a trump
referendum
elder is the uh epitome of the pro-trump
lunatic
um so i actually think this could be
very bad for trumpism
explain how this works if gavin is
recalled is elder automatically the
governor or is there another election
and democratic candidate no so it's
basically a two-part let's go to the uh
data
um here it is so the first question is
should gavin newsom be recalled okay
these numbers are going to start coming
into us in um
76 minutes
if this gets 50
then it goes to the second question
which is who should replace him
the second question is only enabled it's
like it's got to be unlocked in a sense
if the first one gets 50
i believe the first one will not get 50
percent
okay we're just waiting for the data
waiting for the data
um let's see what else we've got going
on here
rob roster dropping in a twenty dollar
super chat appreciate that
i know he's toxic but jesse lee peterson
is your riley martin no all right
david can you explain why california
even has recall elections to begin with
are you surprised people haven't fought
for federal recall elections
um
no i mean it the system california has
is absurd
so um
it needs to be it needs to be fixed
actually
tony win besting the 50 super chat with
a hundred dollar super chat incredible
thank you tony
mr feeny says tell larry elder he can
keep that little smug hey actually i'm
gonna play some video from uh from the
new some rally last night
it was off the wall bonkers but before
we do that i am committed to not falling
behind today
in terms of thanking different people so
i want to say thank you to james brummel
for signing up on my website with the
code no recall and pete zaleski for
doing exactly the same thing that puts
us at two
and then a ton of people signing up here
with twitch prime
let me see who we've got i want to say
thanks to robin your rhubarb
lesson on
pac fans
sarah dames
m bronov
shiny socks it's gimli jen here has
gifted two
milo wild has resubbed
hobo spidey big papa pickle abivens
hat mumfree
ernie
black msn
and c mizzle that's 17 guys putting us
at 19 right at the top of the show
what a night
and as a reminder because the theme
today is no recall
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
uh really generously
reminding us with a very controversial
dress some people felt that this dress
should not have been even made actually
uh reminding us that the coupon code on
my website is no recall if you've been
thinking about signing up today is
really a great day to do it
okay let's go to oh you guys are going
to love this we did a segment on the
youtube channel about this but i want to
look at it
with you this is last night at the gavin
newsom joe biden event okay
and
it was absolute and total chaos now what
i'm gonna what you're gonna see here is
there are two
lunatics involved in arguments outside
the event
one of them is an air force mom based on
her shirt they're both unmasked and it
you actually have it's a struggle to
keep track of what is happening here
take a look
so you've got air force mom i believe
arguing about vaccines and you have this
woman arguing about the economy they are
both against gavin newsome
you almost it's like we need
multi-threading to follow with what's
going on she just said do your research
because you're wrong about vaccines she
just said something about a million
dollars her concerns are economics
so now air force mom is asking how many
people have died from the vaccine
tell me because i know
there's over hundreds of thousands
in less than one year so i think she's
saying there are there are hundreds of
thousands of deaths from the vaccine i
think that that's what she's saying in
less than one year sweetheart
happening
do you know how many people die from the
crew your business
the brainwashed person is the one who
doesn't believe hundreds of thousands of
people died from the vaccine size of
coconut honey not everybody dies of
coconut coconut has a 99 survival what's
with sweetheart and honey and stuff like
that by the way why do i know vaccines
why do my kids you
if the vaccine works
i don't want my kids to have something
stuck up their nose every week
that's the problem if the vaccine works
then why are they friendly
tell me why explain that explain it
completely okay so there's air force mom
and then it just like kept going
growing up to do your research
it looks like now this woman is starting
to argue with this woman
all right so now this woman's all just
worked up about taxes
illegal immigrants have more rights than
we do
okay
all right so anyway that was at the uh
that was at the new some rally yesterday
and uh it's it's all it's all pretty
weaponized guys i'm not going to lie i
do want to say thank you to megan roller
megan just signed up on my website with
the coupon code no recall very much
appreciate that megan thank you also
want to say thank you to lamberfs bling
bling dabani
scientific
um for signing up via twitch
putting us already at 23 which i very
much appreciate results in 69 minutes if
you can believe it let's get to
oh
let me do oh actually hold on a second
let me do should i do unban requests no
so let me just do this this real quick
and i need a sip of water here excuse me
one-handed if you can see that yesterday
i told the story
that i got a bad haircut
whoa what is this
oh my god where are we
youtube movies what is this hold on let
me let me find what i wanted to play for
you guys
um i told the story yesterday that i got
a bad haircut
and
someone made a video about it
here it is this is nicely done this is
user independent
nn
on the subreddit all right this is
pretty well done
hi hey hi hey
how come you're wearing a hat
i got a haircut
oh yeah
can i see it
there's nothing to say
come on let me see it
look at it come on
all right
[Laughter]
very good thank you
all right so anyway yeah i am getting
the haircut fixed on uh on friday my
normal person was not available i ended
up at a barber shop which i love i love
the whole vibe at barber shops i just
got a bad haircut at the barber shop
and um it could even it could even be my
response i might have asked for the
wrong thing okay all right let's
continue other super chats coming in
um sir are you expecting
massive dumps tonight they call them
dumps we are expecting huge vote dumps
coming in yep
jc says david saludo
thank you i appreciate that
matthew haley coming in with a very
healthy 75 super chat
thanks to maria david where can we get a
list of all the effery larry elder wants
to set in place check his wiki we went
over it yesterday and it was just wacky
tony crump says elder is a nut will
never win in california he can dream on
but it will be a nightmare for him
let's hope you're right one dead chicken
says this is awful well let's get
through it together we're 67 minutes
from the results coming in
really appreciate your coverage and
insight analysis of all these elections
long time listener third time super
chatter keep it up david and team thanks
brian
appreciate that
her saying sweetheart is pretty much the
female equivalent of calling a black
person boy do people agree with that do
you guys do you guys think that's true
with the auntie uh with the air force
anti-vaxx mom
everybody seems to be saying not even
close
people disagree
speaking of the
pol from cali and san fran in boehner's
new book he claims pelosi is the most
powerful speaker in his lifetime maybe
ever what's with san fran and pelosi
newsom harris
i don't know i'm not sure i know what
you mean i'd have to think about that
you have to think about that
ben says any takes on the boston and
somerville races
um
do i want to mention anything about that
i mean listen um
i i've sort of been in touch with
michelle wu off and on for a couple of
years
and um
if i were a boston voter i'd be voting
for michelle wu i like michelle very
very strongly somerville i know nothing
about
illinois governor pritzker signing clean
energy tomorrow boosting solar and wind
closing all coal and gas over the next
two decades i will cover that rob
appreciate you letting me know
would you say this is a good test to see
who would win in california in 22 for
house races no
no remember house races are district by
district tonight's recall is statewide
this is more analogous to senate in a
sense okay
um in a sense i want to say thank you to
aj for a you as well as merkellist bobby
and bernie on a boat for re-upping
twitch subscriptions today also thanks
for people signing up on my website
brandon gullet just signed up with the
code no recall julie spalding is a new
member and so is johnny boliera
numbers 28 29 and 30. we are here
awaiting results in the california
gubernatorial recall i don't just want
the recall to fail
i want the recall to get crushed
okay and because of that the coupon code
on my website is no recall it's a simple
code
no space no recall
we're at 30 we're going for a hundred
joinpakman.com is the place to do it and
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
setting the world ablaze almost broke
the internet
uh showing up today
um with address reminding everybody of
the discount code no recall no recal
call discount code as opposed to of
course
total recall a very very different thing
we're going to be joined momentarily by
one of the candidates tonight his name
is kevin paffraff he is running
let me check in with him
hey are you almost ready to go
a scheduled for the top of the hour
kevin actually you know kevin would
outlaw the coupon code and so we're
going to talk with him about that
momentarily because um
i believe the coupon codes should be
legal
i believe that they should be legal
kevin may disagree
all right so we're gonna hear about that
oh let me quickly do my unban requests
i'm just gonna lean over and and grab my
gavel
okay here we go when you get banned on
twitch
you can request to be unbanned and i
will adjudicate it and then uh this is a
chord of just one okay
user matt zeeman
was recently
banned
he generally was being negative
he said he
gives props to larry elder
he thinks biden has dementia
he thinks it's embarrassing that i was
using wikipedia to tell you some of
larry elder's political opinions even
though they were all very clearly cited
matt zeman was banned
and he is asking to be unbanned and says
david i apologize for being rude i don't
know what got into me i enjoy your
channel it helps educate me i won't be
mean or be out of line if given another
chance that's fair
i am going to unban i think that that's
fair
what they said was not uh
you know racist anti-semitic etc
um
okay now it said that that had already
been resolved guys if there are any
moderators
messing with the unban requests please
do not touch them okay please do not
touch them because i do them on air in
the time it said someone already did
that some other moderator moderators
please do not touch those next one is a
user named labontek is fake
i recognize this this is someone who's
been banned under a dozen or so
different names already they made a new
account yesterday followed yesterday and
immediately posted the message what's up
libtard they were banned
and they came in and
they said a libtard moderator did this
and i'm waiting on my moderator
application unfortunately that's going
to be
another perma-ban
okay
so
from the standpoint of unbanned requests
we are all set
we've taken care of them
results in an hour guys results in an
hour
let's um
we're standing by for kevin paffraff
here but he's not
we'll give him another minute supposed
to be joining us right now
we are ready when you are
hopefully he doesn't bail on us you know
all right
we're standing by for that i'm just to
do a few super chats while we wait for
kevin because i don't want to be
interrupted in the middle of some of the
other material let's continue
um
sir thanks for staying up past your
bedtime to do the stream glad you have
glad to have you in the living room
tonight appreciate it thank you very
much thank you very much
david sir would you ever consider
running for public office why or why not
i don't know maybe you know
i have no strong feeling about it one
way or the other
alex coming in with a hundred dollar
super chat matching the high water mark
of the night as we cross into seven
thousand live viewers over on youtube
and approaching one thousand live
viewers on twitch
sir what's the reasoning behind
republicans saying elections are rigged
it's really troubling if this is the new
norm well they can't win on policy so
basically it's
do cultural stuff and then say it was
stolen it's
i don't
i hesitate to call it a strategy because
it's so idiotic
but it's sort of like their strategy
because they're losing on policy
you know
david reading in politico dems are
looking to include immigration reform in
the 3.5 trillion dollar plan this is
becoming the bill of bills for democrats
yeah you know i am sort of
i'm holding i'm i'm kind of holding
tight
on really analyzing it in as serious a
way as i eventually will
because so much is being thrown around
that i don't actually know what's
ultimately going to be in this thing yet
um
so i'm kind of keeping tabs on what's
being proposed and we'll do the deep
dive when the time comes
how do you think it would affect the
2022 midterms if it came out that biden
had ligma
what's that
i don't even know what that is
sounds pretty based though
hey david coming back to monthly
donations very much appreciate that
kornacki expects results quick because
most ballots are by mail and have been
counted yeah i i again
i think that by um 75 minutes from now
this thing is basically gonna be over
i think it will basically be over all
right guys i'm going to try calling
kevin paffrath i hope he's not bailing
on us let's see
uh
video call
let's see what we've got
doesn't seem like he's on
we were scheduled to speak to one of the
candidates today let me just see
uh paff wrath i'll shoot him a quick
email
hey have been trying to call you
on discord
we'll see if it happens it happens i do
want to say thank you to sarah inscore
who just signed up at joinpakman.com
j.r hobson just signed up at
joinpakman.com
and eddie coke just signed up at
joinpakman.com very much appreciate that
guys also thanks to omnishark hot grease
and under the screen
for the twitch subscriptions numbers 34
35 and 36 very much appreciate that
uh oh okay let's see i think we've got
kevin here
let me see what we've got
we're gonna try
to hear from kevin
kevin paffrath one of the candidates in
today's recall election
uh hey kevin can you hear me
i can hear you perfectly thank you so
much for having me beautiful give me one
second just to get you properly on
screen
uh
i'm just gonna tweak my the shot here
where you don't typically use discord
but i want the audience to have you have
such perfect resolution we want
everybody to be able to see you
uh and there are so many questions
about everything that's going on
um okay so
let's see here and all right good
everybody can now see you kevin it's
great to have you on again
thank you so much i guess no i was on i
was on with you last time really it's
great to be together again i think is
the point
good point that's that's true and and we
didn't even talk about governorship back
then that wasn't even on the radar back
then right
generic stimulus and the large packages
and the small packages going around
which makes me wonder if it was not even
on your radar back then was this like on
a whim
kind of
in fact i decided to run the day before
i declared it so it went mega fast and
the reason was i looked at the ballot
and i'm like oh my gosh there's no
backup option what are they doing the
options were horrible i'm like i can
compete in this oh that's interesting so
you so you were running you're are you
not like a like a hardcore auntie
newsome guy but you felt that if newsom
was recalled it would be really bad so
you wanted to be in there as an
alternative
well it's both i don't love what
newsome's done i think you know this
election has turned into mudslinging
against larry elder and fear-mongering
elder and covid right well elder is
arguably one of the most dangerous
people that could ever hold public
office so i think it's warranted but
maybe we'll get to that
yeah and and look i i
aside from the larry part i which i get
that i get the arguments the the thing
that i think we should be standing on is
policy solutions how are we going to fix
homelessness schools how are we going to
fix the crime problem that we've got the
housing shortage and get enough water to
california and deal with our fires right
yeah these are some massive issues i
wish this election were about that
policy but it's become so much about you
know elder or as the l.a times says the
black face of white supremacy and uh you
know gavin newsom saying hey this is a
trump republican joe biden just
yesterday yeah called larry elder
without mentioning him he didn't i think
you were streaming it actually he didn't
mention larry elder's name once but just
said the other the leading republican is
a clone of donald trump just driving
that fear into california i mean that
seems
absolutely accurate i mean the only
thing i've ever seen larry elder
disagree with trump on
was
elder was against the china tariffs and
otherwise i can't think of a single
thing so it seems he's a clone it seems
it's accurate
you're actually right i mean now that
you got me thinking about it you know i
tried to think more about our campaign
oh okay
right all right good we align perfectly
so it's actually so you so it's it's
okay then for biden to call him a clone
because he's it seems like he is one
you're agreeing
yeah i agree oh okay i said it during
the debate the one debate that i was in
i said look the danger here in
california uh is is we get nothing done
right but there's also a danger of larry
elder if you play back the debate i said
look the danger is not john cox or kevin
kiley or faulkner standing on stage with
me the moderates right i always thought
we're sort of the moderates it's really
it's somebody like either larry elder or
in my opinion i think there's a better
option than gavin newsom whether that's
in this election or next election we'll
see
but uh but golly yeah look i said it as
well so i agree with you hey um one of
the things i think we're seeing in the
exit polls
and i'm curious your thoughts on it is
that some of the issues you mentioned
are not that important to the voters or
at least the voters who voted so far
what i mean by that is you talked for
example about crime i think only one out
of 10 voters said that's the top issue
whereas the plurality was actually
covid
where
elder said end every mask requirement
end every vaccine requirement so it
seems maybe
there was a miscalculation about what
the voters care about
there was a transition
and it was really with the rise of the
delta variant which you can look at the
rise of cases starting the very last two
or three days of july
and the first two weeks of august the
delta variant took over news headlines
yeah fear was ever we went to peak delta
fear and if you look at the polls larry
elder just got into the election right
in mid-july like july 13th uh the and as
soon as the beginning of august came
around gavin newsom released marketing
going here's larry elder he's going to
take away all of the covert requirements
at the same time as p we're getting to
peak delta basically and people here
over delta school's reopening the timing
was a gift for gavin newsom it literally
larry elder was was the perfect gift for
gavin newsom's campaign and you're right
look we ran this campaign when we
started in may and june on the issues
that mattered then the number one issue
then was homelessness the number two
issue was housing the number three issue
was crime and then water and fires those
were the big issues that's what we built
our campaign on that shifted just in
those first two weeks of august uh and
yeah that that hurt okay yeah i don't
have the polling as of that date in
front of me so i'll have to i'll have to
take your word for it on that listen
kevin on on raking the forest floors
are you in favor of raking are you
against it do you think it's neither
here nor there
yeah
i'm not sure about ranking but i am for
controlled burns so i'm a big fan of how
can we get uh logging back on our
federal lands so we got to cooperate
with joe biden how can we get logging
back on our california lands where we
need to do controlled burns anyway then
conduct control burns controlled burns
cost 35 dollars an acre wildfires cost
1500
an acre portugal had what extreme
wildfires up to 2017 they went crazy
uncontrolled burns
the economist did a whole piece on this
that's the economist economist.com and
uh they talked about exactly how they
went through this controlled burn
strategy and now they don't have as bad
of devastating wildfires they haven't
had a devastating wildfire since they've
had wildfires but not as devastating
like what we're seeing here in
california and here's the problem npr
did a whole expose on this gavin newsom
declared that he was going to do x
number of acres of controlled burns he
overstated how much he actually did by
690 percent
then the day npr released that report
the cal fire chief appointed by newsome
tried to cover that fact up and at the
same time they're trying to now publicly
walk back that they ever made that
commitment so had we done more
controlled burns i think we could have
helped to put a dent in the wildfires
that we're having now but we need to do
a lot more than even they were trying to
do we got to think big about these
problems one of the areas you know on a
lot of different things in looking at
your campaign platform it's quite
similar to both gavin newsom and joe
biden you know on masking and vaccines
and on a lot of different things the the
one where i'm trying to understand and
you're running as a democrat for people
who who may be watching and don't know
the one i want to know more about is on
the homelessness issue i'm trying to
figure out where do the homeless go are
do you kick them out of the state of
california is that what you do no
no no no you don't so here's here's what
we got to do for we got to understand
what causes homelessness first so the
quick background
seventy percent of homelessness is
caused by economic reasons right job
loss eviction poverty right lack of
schooling whatever so we got big issues
structural issues there uh but once
people are homeless they fall into
despair drugs alcohol mental health
issues all of that the issue in
california is we don't have solutions
for those folks that are streamlined and
concentrated and consolidated in one
place you you're homeless how are you
supposed to buy yourself an uber to go
to primary care physician to get a
mental health appointment six months out
it's impossible so what happens you live
on the street and you just want to be
left alone because the system sucks so
here's my plan
we convert 80 buildings throughout the
state of california uh so maybe to a
house an average of about 2 000 folks
each some will be smaller some will be
larger and in these they're optional
facilities but in these we provide
shelter we provide storage for people's
things we provide and i think coveted
like javits center style uh so it's not
like we're giving homes it's it's
shelter is what it is shelter first then
in these facilities we also provide what
we're not doing right now mental health
services drug services clean food clean
clothing opportunities to have like a
base and try to launch from somewhere
again we start with these as optional
facilities
ideally at some point we transition to
where we can say
no more living on the streets because
right now it is against the law but it's
only against the law if there's an
alternate place for people to sleep
that's what we're going to create and we
want to do that as soon as practically
possible because it's unacceptable that
people are dying on the street yeah i
mean i love the idea of creating the
places to go and the places are lacking
in many locations i think the concern is
when when any kind of criminalization of
homelessness has been done
it it often backfires both practically
and from a sort of empathy standpoint so
that would be maybe a concern and you
know if someone's in san francisco and
the closest facility for lack of a
better term is 200 miles away that may
be 200 miles from their family or their
community right so forcing people a lot
going on there kevin by the way forcing
people to go uh that far may not make
sense right
yeah look we absolutely need to put
these facilities where people are there
are more people home i mean we've got
somewhere around 80 000 people homeless
in los angeles right so you're going to
have more facilities there here's just
an example the best example i could give
you is people are like well i don't want
this facility in my backyard and it's
like well wait a minute the homelessness
is where it is the homeless problem on
venice beach or downtown san francisco
is there that's where the facility goes
so if we've got homeless in san
francisco they get serviced with the
facility there if we've got homeless in
venice they get serviced with the
facility there so we've got to bring the
services to them we can't ship people
out to other states or the deserts we
can't arrest our way out of homelessness
that's ridiculous it's not their fault
they're homeless it's government's fault
to in most cases it's government's fault
that has failed people with a proper
social safety net it's not fair to them
like look at our schools we're the fifth
largest economy in the world and we're
in the bottom 20 of schools it's crazy
uh and so in my opinion we've got to
make big investments into uh not only
helping the people who are on the
streets now but then breaking the cycle
of poverty yes we do that by investing
in our schools and solving our crime
crisis kevin kevin do you have to go i
don't want to keep you if you've got to
run it seems like a lot is going on
there
i've you know i'll actually i'll
actually take you yeah come on over
we've got like an event i'll just take
you over here i hope i don't lose you
over here oh there's an event happening
right now
well i mean we're kind of
oh wow it sounds loud everybody
vaccinated in there god i hope so
let me see hold on a second let me see
what time spectrum is because we've got
an interview coming up yeah
let me interview the spectrum person
7 20. okay i got five minutes oh okay
perfect um listen uh i will interview
the spectrum reporter momentarily
that'll be interesting for the audience
real quick real estate question are you
still big on radon tests no matter what
as part of the inspection do you think
that that just always makes sense just
for peace of mind
no i it's not necessary in most areas
we're in a high rate on area technically
but we
we almost never do radon tests i
actually have done radon testing before
though and when radon testing is
important is certainly first in areas
that are known to have high radon but
number two when you have cracked
foundations and then really well
insulated homes see that's actually an
interesting combination because if you
have homes from the 1920s and 50s
they're not well insulated so the radon
can come in and kind of ventilate out so
you generally don't get bad
concentrations the homes built in the
50s here in california they don't even
have insulation in the walls it's not
right
the problem is when you get like 2003
build homes that are really well
insulated and then they've got these
massive foundation cracks and that radon
leaks in in a high rate on area in those
areas absolutely radon test last
question even if you're paying cash is
it useful to throw a mortgage
contingency in there just to give you an
extra out
no no no no no because if you're if
you're saying you're paying cash and
you're putting in a mortgage contingency
nobody's going to believe you you don't
need an extra out like that what you
should always have is
like bare minimum title report that is
your most important contingency i just
bought a property wrote a cash offer no
inspection no finance no appraisal
contingency i get the title report back
they had they told me they had like a
new roof and a new air conditioner new
windows and i saw this i'm like this is
great i'm getting a great deal title
report comes back those are all pace
loans it was like 90 000 worth of loans
and they were expecting me to take that
over and i'm like no you're selling me
the house with these upgrades you pay it
off that's not my problem pay off your
loans so that was you're out
wow yeah well but by using that out i
convinced them to pay those debts off
and so now we're still closing cash wow
well kevin it's all happening
absolute last thing i know you got to go
by how much does gavin recall end up
staying today he's going to crush it
right
you know what look it's and to me it's
gonna come out to the millennial turnout
that's the big thing if millennials turn
out uh we can we can pull this off but
millennials they don't show up in these
surveys and it's important to know the
millennials biggest voting base but
again
lowest turnout historically right was i
able to drive him out we'll see if i get
enough of a turnout uh who knows we
could win if we don't win and we have a
lot of momentum we'll go strong into
2022 uh and uh and if we totally
miscalculated and nobody votes for us
well then probably won't go into 2022.
right see what happens
all right kevin you've said it all i
appreciate you making time for us on
such a busy day for you
thank you so much for having me all
right we'll talk to you soon take care
everybody
thanks bye see ya
all right folks kevin paffrath
maintaining
polite optimism about the circumstances
in california
um he may end up with somewhere between
six and ten percent of the recall vote
uh for for those who on the second
question is what i'm trying to say
we are down to 42 minutes until the
results
i believe
i personally believe right like miss
south carolina
that gavin newsom is going to do really
really well tonight
i really think so i really think so okay
um boy do i have a lot of people to
thank here we have such an incredible
night we are about to breach
the firewall of 8 000 live viewers on
youtube
we are closing in on 1500 on twitch and
500 on facebook we may get to that 10
000 total mark today because it is an
important day the california
gubernatorial recall is a referendum on
trumpism as kevin admitted after first
saying he didn't get it but then i
convinced them
uh larry elder is essentially a trump
clone
uh different skin color yeah okay i get
it um
but on policy
and we are really going to get a signal
potentially
about some elements of trumpism for 22
based on what happens today so the theme
today is
no recall
no recall that's the coupon code on my
website i will even show you
uh how it all works here what am i even
clicking here you go to my website and
look aoc even modeling the coupon code
for us very controversial dress okay
you pick monthly or yearly i say yearly
because you save even more
the coupon code no recall
60
a fair price
becomes just
i don't even i'm not allowed to say it
out loud my lawyer says don't say it out
loud it it's on the screen is what it is
it's just such a discount okay
um so i encourage people to take
advantage of that as we are now just
moments moments from the first results
um oh and on that note i'm sorry
let me just thank everybody who signed
up gustavo chavez
has just signed up
liam hwitt is a new member alex acrush
has signed up as has michael randall
thanks to mark oppenheimer as well
that puts us at 41
and then i also want to thank everybody
who's been supporting via twitch which
includes the hobo
santa araz
jr dubs grant metal head jpt
um
is that it yeah okay that's it that's
five
putting us at 46. very much appreciate
that i know people are worried can the
website handle all of this traffic we've
quadrupled resources on the website just
to make sure it could handle the traffic
all right let's go through a few
different things that i had for you here
we'll get back to that
um okay this was a poll worker
in west hollywood this morning wearing a
trump hat
and a where's hunter shirt how is the
isn't this
electioneering at the polling place now
i guess the counterpoint would be
these individuals hunter and trump are
not on the ballot in the election that
he is working
um
but i think the point that people are
making in chat is
even if it's not electioneering this
doesn't appear to be a neutral observe a
neutral individual
so yeah
that's a concern for sure it strikes me
as against the law
here is larry elder previously just to
give you a sense of how horrifying this
guy is
saying that he would have voted against
the civil rights act of 1964 oh boy
when i said to this man that i was a
libertarian he said wait a second
libertarian i had the libertarian
candidate for
vice governor of new york on my show
and i asked him
when you were in the senate in the mid
60s
would you have voted in favor or against
the civil rights legislation in 1964 and
this man said he would have voted
against it so i'm asking you larry elder
what would you have done
and i said well to the extent that those
laws
mandate
any kind of interference in the private
sector yes i would have voted against it
you guys know why that's funny right
he's telling us here
his
godly principle is
no
interference in the private sector this
guy is running on if you elect me i will
ban businesses from enforcing mass
mandates
and i will ban businesses from requiring
vaccination
think about that
his guiding principle don't interfere
with business
except he's running on i will tell
businesses exactly
how they can determine who to do
business with and who not to do its
irony is dead
irony is dead this guy's disgusting we
we've got to crush him today
um
oh okay i will be
covering this tomorrow because it did
start to get some attention
as many of you know the
pop
singer
nicki minaj tweeted a very strange story
about vaccination yesterday
tweeting my cousin in trinidad won't get
the vaccine because his friend got it
and became impotent his testicles became
swollen his friend was weeks from
getting married now the girl called off
the wedding so just pray on it make sure
you're comfortable with your decision
not bullied yesterday i responded to
this and some people like this i said is
it maybe possible that the the swollen
apple bags were an std from cheating and
that's why the wedding was called off
now some of you yesterday said david sir
there's no std that would cause that uh
you were wrong about that actually
chlamydia and gonorrhea
which can be which are stds
can cause inflammation of the testicle
or kitis
okay so i don't even know why i trusted
you guys when you told me that but a
very very important apple bag situation
which we're still investigating strongly
jake tapper did ask anthony fauci about
it today
um let's just take a quick look at what
dr fauci said sp speaking of uh trusted
messengers
and pop star nicki minaj tweeted
yesterday that she's not vaccinated
she's doing her own research and then
she shared an anecdote i found rather
unbelievable to be honest about alleged
side effects that her cousin's friend
supposedly experienced in trinidad i
wouldn't normally even ask you about
this but but nicki minaj has nearly 180
million followers on twitter and your
instagram combined she's beloved by her
fans she's a huge talent obviously her
tweet was seized upon by vaccine
opponents as some sort of evidence
i want you to address what she said
because for anyone out there who has any
questions about this
dr fauci is there any evidence fauci
addressed the apple bag swelling that
the pfizer the mederna or the j j
vaccines cause any reproductive issues
in men or women
the answer to that uh jake is a
resounding error
there's no evidence that it happens nor
is there any mechanistic reason to
imagine that it would happen
so the answer to your question is no
how can health authorities all right
anyway you guys get the picture i think
you're understanding uh what's going on
there so we did our orchitis elements as
well
um
yeah very good
okay we are
35 minutes from results starting to come
in we are monitoring right-wing channels
we are monitoring left-wing challenge
channels this is newsmax live what is
their story
we don't know if we can trust the
election and here's lindsey graham
telling us about it news is that even if
he doesn't get it this time he's got
another shot here in about amen and i
want to ask you one more question a
question we get all the time from our
viewers the associated press
uh reported last month uh you and susan
collins had supported all eight biden
judges that had been confirmed and
republicans get really heated over this
story and i wanted to give you a chance
just to respond yeah to that story sure
sure
well i was the chairman yeah i
appreciate it i was the chairman of the
judiciary committee who were confirmed i
think two all right whatever we don't
really care what lindsay says but
they're already pulling the voter fraud
um
uh stuff they're not stopping with it
hold on i think i have a fraud here we
go fraud
fraud
fraud it's a fraud exactly and that's
what they are claiming at this point in
time all right i i apologize that i have
gotten away from super chats let me
answer a few
oh my god first i've got to thank all
these people or we are never going to
catch up
center safe and scruts commander have
signed up via twitch i appreciate that
guys
uh it would really be something else if
we can get up to a thousand from the
standpoint of twitch also
memberships are dumping in on my website
i don't know that we've ever seen this
happen
let me thank people taking advantage of
the coupon code no recall on my website
okay
andrew sorensen
is a new member
daniel hall has signed up priscilla
medina using the code
jean bison is a new member
seth daniel and jacob kotis have signed
up
jesse guthrie and braden neves are new
members
ian le philippe
not le phillip le philip
and carly knight have signed up
rebecca
scheele
and kathy d filippo are new members jay
isberg as well as wayne smith have
signed up
katherine goodman and linda goran are
new members
i don't even know that we can keep up
nick lewis as well as mario hernandez
ethan apodaca
gail long
and micah o'leary folks that's 21
putting us
at 69.
we must stop the count people are
demanding there's people already saying
the count has been rigged which is crazy
all right let me get to some super chats
big boo boo says david what's your
favorite kubrick film
um 2001 a space odyssey i would say
david what do you think of the grateful
dead not a fan and i also am off cherry
garcia i have found a better cherry ice
cream it is greyton's we did a whole
segment on it grayton's a black cherry
it is the best cherry ice cream not a
sponsor
didn't cinema run as a progressive i
didn't think so
i didn't think so matt wilson says keep
the mark rising yes matt wilson has now
set a new high-water mark for us
for super chats with 101 tonight thank
you matt
sharon says thanks for doing the
election coverage thank you for being
here sharon i appreciate it we have
surpassed 10 000 live viewers at this
point in time
uh we are uh combined right now
at uh 10
600 live viewers across platforms i have
only you to thank here
can i check on how covet is doing in
california yeah that's a good idea
actually
let's take a look at that
what is the trajectory in california
um so it looks like they got the wow
their delta bump was not as big
proportionately as in some places and
already declined about uh
what is that about 30 percent
that's cases let's look at deaths
okay death's actually rising
um so
you know i mean i guess we can say
relatively controlled spike compared to
other places
but
not great
much like much of the country is
experiencing
we are moments from election results
folks appreciate you being here do you
think we will get a voting rights bill
i i don't want to be negative but i
don't think so
i hate to say it but i don't think so
dr dan burrito man says ligma okay yeah
i'm not falling for it i'm a democrat
was going to vote yes on recall when
larry elder showed up i realized the big
lie has infested my beloved california i
voted no well done
what's your opinion of scott perry i
have no idea who that is
scott perry i i don't know who scott who
is that
scott perry
oh he's a congressman
yeah i don't know i don't know anything
about him
um dude is chaotic evil
i just finished precinct walking in
support of the governor democrats are
out voting to keep newsom in office the
recall was a waste of time i believe in
the end it will have been a waste of
time matt wilson asking could kevin
screw up the recall by splitting the
vote or does it not work like that it
doesn't work like that if new the it's
so we actually have
let's get to the results here
it's a two-part
ballot okay should newsome be recalled
unless this gets to 50 it doesn't go any
further
and that's it
only if the answer to should he be
recalled is yes would it then move into
the second part
okay so no need to worry about that we
are moments moments from starting to see
those results roll in
um
don't texas our california yeah well
said
uh will you live stream on the 18th
so here's the deal on the 18th
i've got to go to a wedding at 6 eastern
probably have to leave at 5 30.
got to hop in the shower at 4 30. so if
the if the rally slash riot is starting
at like noon or 1 i will stream for a
couple of hours i think it would be
important to do that
but
you know at a certain point i will have
to run
david what's your favorite shiraba mate
brand i don't drink mate never liked it
your new haircut is so so have you ever
thought about growing a rat tail no i
have not
um
what's your favorite pixar movie
i i don't think i've seen a pixar movie
in 20 years
i love mallory good
i voted no and i did it three times
because i'm corrupt
yeah i hope that's a joke happy birthday
thank you not my birthday 2001 is good
have you seen barry lyndon i have not
seen it sam and emma spent a majority of
the show this this morning debating no
mickey on the absurdity of aoc promoting
her coupon code dress glad to tune into
something of substance oh that's
interesting
david do you think nicki minaj was paid
for the tweet it just seems so weird
no i don't think so
sir nice haircut rudy isn't the only one
primping at applebee's yes thank you
very much i appreciate that
um welcome if you are just joining us we
have an incredible incredible evening
ahead of us where i am hoping for
i am wishing for i am
praying for no
no but
colloquially i am really hoping
for a crushing
of the recall movement and we are going
to have results
in 27 minutes 27 minutes i believe this
is not going to be a late night i mean
it's late i mean it's three hours past
my bedtime obviously but what i mean is
i think we are going to know by 11 15
whether this is uh
going to recall or not now if it goes to
recall i don't know if we'll necessarily
know tonight who wins although i think
it would be elder
i think we're going to know by about 11
15. i'm kidding guys no i go to bed
around now normally
um
so many i've gotta i've gotta thank a
few more people because so many people
are signing up on my website we have a
very special coupon code today no recall
thanks to aoc's dress very very uh uh
it's a designer dress quite frankly
benjamin rangel just signed up using the
code at joinpacman.com
john mayan just signed up hugo sanchez
is a new member justin curtis has signed
up
thanks to jonathan brown as well as
dionne
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
cole bidet and peter palath have signed
up
douglas hoover and logan de hoyas are
new members
johnny terrado and derek smith thank you
for signing up buck walker and barrett
urban are new members michelle patrick
has signed up so is daniel dock
and uh julie jones is a new member
that's 15
putting us
at 84. what a day what a day also thanks
to everybody watching on twitch we are
at 1500 viewers on twitch for the first
time in a long time thanks to a hick
as well as spider monkey
infiniflip bigfoot tornado
get sauced
all of whom are supporting via twitch
and twitch prime
and related twitch products
um
i'm going to play
a few voicemails
just because people are asking for them
it is not the subject today
but we are moments from the recall
results and i want to just play a few of
these for people just to give you a
sense of the flavor
of what's going on
hi david it's mike in buffalo new york
and i had a question for you
if in afghanistan
the taliban is going to be a good faith
actor in the world
why are they cutting off evacuations
august 31st they're not going to be a
good faith actor nobody i don't know who
said that i certainly did not say that
myself
hey david i wanted to get your take on
this weird argument that came up from a
right winger on
covid vaccine mandates so i was talking
about
a friend of mine who's in a deep red
state idaho
and a registered nurse at a hospital
where it's required that everyone has
the vaccine
now
seventy percent of her department
actually is not working right now
because they refuse to get the vaccine
again it's a deep red state so
um my friend said
my conservative friend said wouldn't
that go in the negative category for uh
for
mandates
okay i'm gonna move on from that let's
listen to
just a couple of others oh actually
before i continue with this
let me actually play a couple of the
other clips that i did have
um
hold on so we did the nicki minaj stuff
oh okay yeah so
this is that lunatic attorney lynn wood
i don't fully know what happened here
but apparently so so here's ron
phillipkowski who's really good with
with covering all of this insanity
here's the explanation for what we're
about to see
after attempts to force a chicago
hospital to treat anti-vaccine activists
veronica wolsky with ivor mechtin were
unsuccessful
lynnwood calls the hospital says he has
an ambulance outside to take her away
and that if they don't release her they
could be charged with murder
this is completely insane
yes tell me your name again
jp
my name is lynn wood i'm a lawyer i'm
calling you from south carolina
you have a patient in your hospital
named veronica wolsky
her power her the individual with her
medical power of attorney is demanding
that she be released
immediately there's an ambulance wait
i'm not through yet there's an ambulance
waiting for her outside there is a
medical doctor waiting i'm guessing the
jp on the phone is saying
i can't possibly discuss a patient with
you for her to treat her that's my hippo
if you do not release her you're going
to be guilty of murder do you understand
what murder is now it's really for a
court to decide whether someone's guilty
of something so how a lawyer would be
able to say that
is is absolutely insane so that's lynn
wood
and then i also had this this is from
real america's voice this is apparently
a college student on the right here
who is protesting
vaccines and it just it all makes very
very little sense and it inspires
despair for humanity gonna be a huge
cost to you both financial and otherwise
if you are forced to leave school i mean
how do you go about weighing that cost
in terms of whether or not it's worth it
or not if that's what it comes down to
um so it's for sure worth it um because
i believe that this is just the
beginning um and i think that it's
better if we have more people that would
rise up because then you can nip it in
the bud now rather than it going further
um
so this is like the slippery slope thing
and it's like
hey you know we've had vaccine mandates
of different kinds for at least 116
years and it hasn't gone beyond vaccines
you know we've had vaccine requirements
for a hundred and at least 116 years
they're they're pointing to a slippery
slope where we have 166 116 years of
counterpoint too i think that if we nip
it in the bud now then um
then we'll have choice you know and then
if you don't do it now then they're only
going to slowly take away more freedoms
from you and so really and why hasn't
that happened in 116 years brooke well i
think
i think that people don't feel
that that's what's happening which is
why it's so hard to um get more people
to come together
brooke it's because it's not happening
that's why it's hard to get people to
come together around your insane
slippery slope nonsense
well i know we got you talked about how
they were some of them are vaccinated
some of them are unvaccinated i'm
curious though uh what is the makeup of
the group sort of ideologically of these
90 people are they mostly conservative
are they libertarian also what are their
racial breakdowns and sexual
orientations brook tell us liberal like
is it pretty diverse politically
um so we haven't really talked about
politics um
yeah we don't need to we know who
everybody is it's like what everybody is
um
but we all believe that this is um like
a political theme because we have a
sister school that is in florida and
they're not requiring any of these
things just our school um so it's
clearly political
it's politico
i know there are a lot of people
concerned about these vaccine minutes
pretty much all over the country you
know now that we have dr fauci saying
air travelers should get the coba
vaccine so that would be great i would
love that actually hi
how concerned are you about the impact
on our entire country and sort of where
we're going why do we even care what she
thinks about that she has no idea she's
pointing to an inevitable slippery slope
that over 116 years has not happened
nation
um so it is pretty scary um
like i said earlier like i think it's
just really important for people to keep
pushing for the freedom of choice um
because if we don't have that is she
talking about
freedom of choice like abortion
then um
then you have no rights over your own
body like what would this role come to
you know so oh sort of like all those
people trying to make abortion illegal
is that what you're talking about
i think it is imperative to have more
people rise up whether what what side
you're on rise up yeah okay so that's
what's going on at
the national university of health
sciences not an institution i'm familiar
with at this point in time
but maybe one that i could become
familiar with
let's look at a few other super chats
the dark half is asking sir quick
question ja rule or fat joe ja rule for
sure
did i see trump's full page response to
millie no i bookmarked it but i'm going
to look at it tomorrow
how many dead people do you think are
voting in california tonight we know
republicans will try to find some as
soon as tomorrow yeah i don't think any
i don't think any although it's
conceivable it's conceivable
that someone was alive when they sent in
their mail-in ballot a week ago and then
since died that's that's possible that's
possible they could be of any party when
that happens
um
okay
david are there any states with a
republican governor a democrat can
challenge with a recall i don't know
enough about that to say i don't know
enough to say oh they're at it looks
like this is the elder campaign so let's
take a listen strategists and campaign
uh leaders here in the ballroom of the
hilton in costa mesa as they are seeing
some of these long lines
of long lines across the state but
especially in what they consider to be
gop strongholds like huntington beach
and
a thousand oaks this was another area
mentioned that they are really hoping
that their supporters turn out a very
festive atmosphere at least at this
point here i want to show you the uh
are they bringing out a crudite there
did you guys see the wait staff that
that looks nice looks like there were
some nice carrots there in a crowd of
his supporters he's of course hoping in
celebration now since he got into this
race he jumped to the front of the pack
of the replacement candidates
he really set himself apart from some of
the more moderate replacement candidates
by stressing a conservative agenda
and really leaning into yeah it's called
it's actually trumpism the guy's
policies are almost indistinguishable
from trumpism
um we are standing by for election
results 16 minutes from now folks 16
minutes from now right side broadcasting
is in the room at the larry elder event
newsmax is um
running commercials for
looks like elements of sinks
a malfunction if i've ever seen one uh
okay so very very soon very soon we are
going to have information
about uh the winner here
ten thousand dollars on non-vaccine
people as a bounty i don't know what
that means
national university of health and
sciences is a chiropractic self-ski
healing school not a real medical school
um
and then david national university of
health sciences does not have an md
program but a naturopathic program so
she is not a medical student that's
pretty funny even labeling her as a
medical student seems to have been a bit
of an exaggeration that's actually
hilarious
that is hilarious
um
i do want to thank people who continue
we may set a record today guys hold on a
second stand by
bajibo lasharu
as well as dr daddy have just signed up
via twitch prime over on my website
where we have a
this ends at midnight eastern guys
coupon code no recall
controversial very controversial coupon
code no recall being used
joslyn witt or whit has just signed up
on my website
matthew
corser evan bradley has just signed up
so has colleen kashalk i hope i
pronounced that correctly
philip nado
and stacy fisk
whoa people are stealing memberships
this is crazy
kyle mcavoy
and ali wender have signed up
tracy trish
and ben vanderkolf our new members
brandon korth and susan clatt have
signed up and so has ryan long
putting us at
104
also thanks to mogwai for the twitch
subscription very much appreciate that
um thanks to everybody watching on
twitch by the way really do appreciate
it we've been making every effort to do
more content on twitch
and um
people asking for my thoughts on the aoc
dress i really don't care about it like
i really don't care i i just i i just
don't care
uh we turned it into something funny for
today we did one of our viewers did but
i just don't care about the aoc went to
an event and she wore a dress that said
tax the rich around rich people that
right
you know what whatever
um hard for me to feel too much about it
one way or the other
folks we're moments moments from results
13 minutes until polls close in
california expecting many results
quickly as a result of the
uh heavy
early ballot juan is this kevin right
here we just interviewed kevin that is
kevin right are they covering kevin
pulling democrat taking newsome on and
back out here live he says regardless of
what happens out here tonight he does
plan on running for governor again in
2022.
reporting live we just interviewed kevin
actually about a half hour ago
all right nicole thank you so much for
that update
meantime governor newsom is spending
this election night in sacramento after
making a stop in san francisco okay so
we're keeping an eye on all of it guys
expecting results momentarily
everybody's about to go live
uh let's see if we can actually get to
10 000 live viewers on youtube alone
that would be amazing
questions continue to come in
because the trump cult has spread all
the way to canada i hope this recall
fails so the crazies will be quiet for a
while i don't think they'll be quiet
evan asking do i think we'll see some
massive
dumps tonight
they call them dumps i think we're gonna
see one ballot dump right around 11 p.m
and i think it's going to be over that's
my prediction
that's my prediction i am confident
today i might end up crying by 1105 but
i am i am pretty confident about tonight
uh if you could ask larry elder one
thing right now what would you ask him
i don't know god do you still think the
slave owners should get reparations
i fear democrats are like a lobster who
doesn't realize he's being boiled alive
if push doesn't come to shove whilst the
dems hold executive power the gop is
having lobster for dinner soon
yeah
let's hope not
tristan asking is it just me who boils
over with rage at air force mom no
watching that video i i was pretty fired
up myself
are you taking calls david probably not
it's just a late night so i think we're
gonna we're gonna get to results and
then we may call it
i was doing maintenance today at a
business that hosted sarah huckabee
sanders do you have thoughts on her in
terms of policy yeah her policy is vile
absolutely horrifying it would be a
disaster
for any state to be plagued with her as
governor
um
a lot of people seem focused in on my
apple bags tweet
we can look at it once more
this refers yesterday
nicki minaj
tweeted about hold on where is it
here it is
nicki minaj tweeted about um
some guy whose testicles became swollen
from the vaccine
and i responded is it maybe possible the
swollen apple bags were an std from
cheating and that's why the wedding was
called off
i always sometimes i'd like to see who
quote tweets it
pacman in the comments section
gates foundation has been experimenting
with vaccines for 20 years wow some
people that's bizarre huh
apple bags sir that's a new one okay
yeah i am actually going to talk let me
just show you guys this
this is beyond parody i wasn't initially
going to talk about the nicki minaj
stuff
but check out what happened today on
tucker carlson
we haven't been able to figure out
whether this show is broadcast in
trinidad
but if nicki minaj's cousin's friend is
watching
[Laughter]
oh that is just indistinguishable from
satire that is just it hold on a second
i've got to hear that again
we haven't been able to figure out
whether this show is broadcast in
trinidad
we we haven't been able to figure it out
we just don't know where we're on okay
but if nicki minaj's cousin's friend is
watching
her fiance who's watching we want to
hear your story
we'll come to port of spain to see you
yeah let us know
he's gonna they will go to spain i'm
sorry not to spain to port of spain
trinidad
you really can't i've got what should i
let's craft a tweet i've got a what i
don't even know what to say my instinct
is to say
it's hard to believe that this is real
but it's real
anybody want to craft the the tweet that
should go out with this for me
you guys are probably much more clever
than i am
how does he say this with a straight
face that's not bad
yeah i think i think i like that
man
what a wild wild situation huh um okay
guys we are moments away from results
glad you're with us eight minutes to go
people cannot stop signing up on the
website it's incredible what is
happening right now the website is
straining under the weight
uh raji koja is a new member on my
website david bowles has just signed up
debbie griffith welcome debbie terry
slater signing up with the coupon code
no recall if you forget what the coupon
code is just remember it's on aoc's
dress no recall
thanks to zee buska for the new
membership as well as tammy cox
uh jennifer hall is a new member and so
is amy williams putting us at 113
really appreciate that also thanks to
mikey gaming roni's twitching
dope tipped
for the twitch subscriptions
top of the hour results
did i see the clip with tucker admitting
to lying yes
oh
people are saying that the florida
numbers look like they are they're lies
they are and i'm going to explain it to
you here's what's going on this is
really important to understand okay
florida is do look at that wow it's
going so well in florida
florida is reporting cases
with a full week's delay
okay and then assigning the cases to the
day i'm sorry the deaths assigning the
deaths
to the day that they took place so
here's what happens
for the last few days
okay so if you look at like
two days ago three days ago
there were
very very few reports because a few days
ago
florida announced the numbers
for last week right
uh where they were in the 300s so it
always looks like the recent numbers are
really really low in fact it looks like
multiple weeks here are incomplete it
always looks like there's a precipitous
decline
next week
they'll update the numbers for this week
but it'll look like next week there's a
precipitous decline it's crazy what
florida is doing we've covered it in
detail i won't bore you with with more
of it right now but it's wild it is wild
sir you're experiencing massive
membership dumps they call them dumps
the coupon code is fraud
yeah no we do need to investigate that i
need to thank todd soucy
as well as louis tirado and nick patella
numbers 117 118 and 119. really very
much appreciate that have i seen the jlp
music video based on the in a destiny
interview yet it's safe for work and
hilarious i haven't but i'll look into
it
tucker's loving the energy sir wondering
if the redistricting occurring this year
merits a segment if nicki minaj cousin's
friend is watching try ice
you should tweet i'm listening to tucker
carlson in spain right now hold the s
in pain yeah
yeah i mean that that's
i let me look at that just one more time
because it's so crazy
i i will look at it on my own profile of
course
figure out whether this show is
broadcast in trinidad
but if nicki minaj's cousin's friend is
watching or his former fiance is
watching we want to hear your story
we'll come to port of spain to see you
well tucker my apple bags are the size
of a cantaloupe um that's really the
whole story you know i don't know what
else to tell you
and this was the vaccine yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely definitely was
the vaccine wasn't cheating on my fiance
definitely not no no no no
very strange very very strange
um
okay very good
we are under five minutes from polls
closing let's see if there's any early
data here
not that i am seeing
uh latest polls let's see what else
we've got
um nothing since 806 there is there like
a google
california
recall results
sometimes google will do a thing
no i'm not seeing it let's see what the
new york times has got
nothing yet okay all right good so we
have plenty of uh plenty of sources here
and we are expecting the initial data in
just moments
abc should be starting shortly
uh nbc is live
right side broadcasting oh hold on
they're interviewing people at larry
elder's campaign headquarters this i
have to hear no it's horrible let's talk
about taxes tax is a big thing right now
if this infrastructure bill if it got
passed it would put californians on the
hook of about
60
of uh your income that that your tax 60
percent
if you make 5 million a year
i don't care how you look at it let's
talk about taxes what needs to be done
here oh we need to you know we're the
highest taxed uh state in the country
and we need to uh uh get our homeless
off the off the street and get them
working so they are contributors to
society as well man these people like
they don't know anything huh just a
little bit but he had barack obama and
several others saying vote no on the
recall but not one of those individuals
including barack obama um
said anything about what newsome has
done to help california wow this guy's
killing it huh no
it's incredible that the people that are
against this recall won't give us any
reasons why
gavin newsom should stay in office well
hold on a second
how about the fact that california's
economy is growing so fast
that if it were a country it would be
growing almost as fast as the developing
uh uh nation of china
the maturing
economy of china i guess we would say a
nonpartisan election right you've got
hispanics that voted
60 percent plus in the last election to
put dusan in office
hispanics
so everybody you know republicans
democrats uh
asian americans uh hispanics are all now
disappointed with what newsome has done
he's done that's not true well i guess
we'll see momentarily i think the
magical question is will we know the
results tonight you know we know
considering a lot of ballots it could
take days to count it could took it
could take weeks to count who knows it
could took weeks
it does make you sick to your stomach i
think they need to change that where
election night is election night and
that's it we kind of saw what happened
in the 2020 election when things were
just able to uh jump in
days and afterwards and even weeks
afterwards i don't know who's more
incompetent the interviewer or the
interviewees results because the
democrats those that that like newsom
may be voting early and that may be the
early results so as you indicated in the
days and a week or however long oh so
this guy's lining it up to say even if
it looks like newsome is not recalled
we've got to wait
guys we are really really close to
election results here really really
close
moments from it moments from it i want
to say thank you to yvette guevara
for signing up for a membership on my
website also thanks to eamon mckay
elizabeth ruiz sharon ternoy
rita delgadillo
james hayning
and robin hwitt with i think another
membership i could have sworn i said
robin quit earlier today also thanks to
jen here for gifting a subscription via
twitch appreciate that jen very very
much
we are standing by for results we have
breached the firewall of not only 10 but
11
000 live viewers on youtube
we could if things go right
surpass 2 000 viewers on twitch welcome
everybody if you were just finding us
and you're wondering why i'm here
i don't have an answer to that question
either i thought i was just going to be
in a guy in a room with a microphone
but all of a sudden there's people
watching because we are just moments
from election results moments moments
moments from election results
50 percent
required to recall gavin newsom if the
answer is yes
it will then go to a ballot expected to
be won by lunatic trumpist republican
larry elder
earlier on today we interviewed
democratic candidate kevin pafrath he
was generous with his time and he joined
us
and um we are now
we are now in the money it is after 11
p.m on the east let's listen the
attention of the country with
potentially national implications should
governor newsom lose lots to get to
tonight here's a live look from
sacramento the polls have just closed
but yep people still in line
people have been back to work
and they're like hey gotta get to the
polls right this is the california
museum over there on o street beautiful
building
they're either there to cast a vote in
person this gentleman's ranting i wish
we could hear this guy every single
registered voter 22 million people
received a ballot because of the
pandemic so live look as the polls close
people are in line if you're in line
i vote still counts that's for darn sure
okay the recall coming down to two
simple questions on the ballot shall
gavin newsom be recalled from the office
of the governor if more than 50 vote yes
the governor would be removed from
office and the second question on the
ballot if the governor is recalled who
will replace him 45 candidates were on
the ballot mostly republicans with a
handful of democrats
though no democratic politicians chose
to officially run against newsome if the
governor is ousted all right
over on abc top challenger larry elder
has promised to end all coveted mandates
if he's elected but he's already casting
doubt on the election results before
they're even known we're getting early
exit polls in and our team is standing
by tonight to break down the race what
the campaigns are saying right now and
what comes next we begin with chief
national correspondent matt gutman
[Music]
after the fight of his political life
tonight governor gavin newsom sounding
confident he won't be fired by the
voters of california so what are we
going to do we will turn out and vote no
on this recall do i have your support to
vote no in the closing hours newsome
tried to turn the race into a referendum
on the leading republican candidate to
replace him all right so everybody's
seemingly making time until we have the
results coming shortly
um this is uh these are interviews with
larry elder supporters they are pretty
weaponized full forensic audit i mean
regardless of the outcome because we
want to know that these elections are
fair they have integrity and they're and
they're really i mean if we don't have
fair and transparent elections we have
we don't have a country right absolutely
like i think that
if democrats and republicans they both
we both care about fair elections right
i think that
if democrats think everything's fair
they should be okay with friends got it
same with us we the question is what
evidence do we have that a forensic
audit is necessary and do you know what
a forensic audit is would you know the
difference between a forensic got it and
a chicken patty right both parties
should be okay with so personally i am
of the belief that there should be
audits of every state in every election
because that's what is going to give the
people the the fake good the confidence
the confidence that these things are
fair yeah so that's what that's what i
think and
okay
um all right i am being told that there
is some early data
fro whoa
whoa
very early everybody hold on whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa everybody relax
everybody relax
with under one percent reporting
should i it does does it even matter
with under one percent reporting like it
just doesn't even matter right i mean we
just have to wait okay everybody relax
everybody relax
we're just waiting
under one percent reporting not even
going to mention anything
but the data is starting to come in
the data's starting to come in
um
we should be following
what's the the guy's name is it david
what's his david uh who does who tracks
the calls elections on twitter i want to
have his twit tweet feed up
david um
david wasserman yeah
let's get him up
uh
no that is not him
not sure who that is
is it dave wasserman
ah there it is okay here we go
so that'll give us some information as
well
i'm not sure that he's even covering
this actually oh he may not even be
covering it okay
uh all right guys the data now we're in
something in spanish this is what what
is this some kind of error
all right in any case the new york times
results seem uh seem quite good
let's also check cnn's results which i
am told are even more
updated uh
whoa
six percent reporting
wow
and a 20 point lead for no we're going
to keep watching the next update coming
in four three seconds two seconds one
second
okay no big update there all right so
with six percent reporting
keeping newsom is winning by more than
20 percentage points by more than 20
percentage points
that this is only six percent so we're
keeping an eye on it if you're just
joining us we've been here for some
period of time we've been waiting for
these results and they are now starting
to come in
and all we can do is track them as they
come in if
yes were to win
this would go to a second question which
is well who should be the next governor
and the belief is that larry elder would
easily win that
okay
from the standpoint of polling
the uh
polling was plus
16
the polling was plus 16
for keeping new sum
the results so far
have now
jumped
to plus
43. oh no sorry that's the wrong one no
no no no that's wrong
where where were the ones we're looking
at sorry the cnn ones here we go got a
little carried away with six percent
reporting that was early that was early
with six percent reporting
it is plus 21 for keeping gavin newsom
people already calling for forensic
audits even without knowing what that
means even without knowing why
um the the message today remember
is
no recall
if you are still in line in california
to vote let us know via super chat
let us know
uh but the the the it is no recall
and if you are on my website
remember that the coupon code is also no
recall it was very controversially on
aoc's dress no recall is the code
some really great people taking
advantage of this i want to thank every
one of them if i can get it scott coley
has just signed up on my website so has
glenda mullins
new member ebony hall is here
rosalie martin has signed up
thank you to ariana parson
and pam colstad and jay stewart putting
us at 134 today welcome if you're
watching on twitch it's so great to be
covering this with you we've not had 2
000 live viewers on twitch for months
it's great to see all of you here we are
at 15 000 concurrent live viewers across
all platforms as we are all anxiously
awaiting now with seven percent
reporting up to a 22 point lead for
keeping gavin newsom my belief is we
need to this can't be close
these recallers need to be humiliated
and destroyed
they need to be humiliated and destroyed
and currently
no is winning
by
22.2 22.2
as we are getting updates
pretty regularly here
and we may by 1115 have
12 or 15 percent of the vote in
it is something else folks
joshua says the first results include
san diego and historically red city
that appears to be true
68 reporting in san diego no winning by
20 points wow
that is interesting and a little bit of
results from no results yet from yolo
but results from napa now isn't napa
sort of conservative also
from what i recall
i am being told that there is now uh oh
with eight percent in
the new york times now has the lead at
plus 23
for keeping gavin newsom
eight percent reporting the lead is plus
23 for keeping gavin newsom
kornacki says expect major counties in
the first half hour yeah we're gonna
know a lot in the next 20 minutes guys
we're gonna know a lot in the next 20
minutes eight percent reporting on new
york times
17 whoa
with 17
reporting
keeping new sums lead has swelled
to almost
uh to almost
28 points
absolutely
huge dump of ballots they call them
dumps exactly 17 in
folks this is this is going
in a very interesting direction
uh i am being told the website
maybe even going down under heavy loads
people trying oh my god is it we've
quadrupled resources
and people may be trying to sign up for
membership so quickly
this can't be possibly happening is it
no the website is still up and running
wow i actually thought the website was
going down there it's like
they don't have any higher hosting plan
than the one we're on guys
um
wow
i love people on twitch saying you only
have 2 000 viewers it's like yeah
there's 16 000 on all these different
platforms i can assure you the website
can't handle 16 000 visitors
uh
most like they're actually you know it
it actually requires quite a significant
website to handle 16 000 people at once
um we just have you know a little old
country website
let's continue to track the numbers
the latest update remains 17
the um
no which would keep gavin newsom
currently leading by 27.4 27.4 dumps
um mccarthy and mcclintock are the
reddest california counties if they vote
no it's over
uh have i watched the netflix
documentary turning points 911 i've not
i have not
we are getting very close to another
vote update here
this is this is it folks this is it
let's see
what's happening
at uh larry elder's headquarters here
victory
that we don't trust in politics and we
don't trust in our money we don't trust
in our stuff
we trust in the god of heaven and earth
is this guy praying for help they're
gonna need the listen it's looking like
you're gonna need divine intervention
the way it's going guys and we're asking
you to take the state back
this guy seems high as a kite when all
god's people said
amen god bless you guys
[Applause]
so two realities shaping up here my
friends from the standpoint of uh voting
we now have 19 reporting and a 29 point
lead for those seeking to keep gavin
newsom
this is what's happening with data
at larry elder's headquarters they are
praying impromptu co-host for the night
sarah rodriguez a friend of mine 2a
advocate
california residents she's very
outspoken you you also work with some
other organizations uh turning point i
think is one of them organizations even
more vile than this network even we have
a long night ahead of us but
but it may not be that long phil you've
seen all the efforts i don't know what
this guy's name is actually expect what
do you see on the streets
well it's hard to to figure out what we
can expect
between
you know fraudulent things going on and
it's a really eloquent articulate
explanation
um it's very confusing right now it is
very
you know it's not looking that confusing
over on cnn's website
with 19 reporting
gavin newsom is prevailing by 29 points
at this point in time with more updates
coming
we are expecting
some sizable data dumps in the next 15
minutes
um
over on uh the new york times with 20 oh
the new york times is up to 21 reporting
and the lead has now swelled to 30.6
this is the biggest lead of the night if
we look at the county by county results
we do have red
elements
everywhere now red is good this is
backwards red is good even yolo
yolo going basically
uh 73 to 27 in the right direction
and i am being told
that dave wasserman has called it
let's take a look
i've seen enough the vote to recall
california governor gavin newsom
has
failed big massive dumps they call them
dumps
dumps and of course the calls of fraud
will start very quickly fraud
fraud
fraud
it's a fraud right
ladies and gentlemen
uh
humiliating i would even say and
humiliating defeat
for those seeking to remove gavin newsom
in the midst of
an extraordinarily powerful
economic situation in california
and replace him
with a man who could be
certifiably insane i mean i don't you
know it's
we're not playing coy with mental
illness larry elder
the the leader among the yes people
seems to be completely out of his mind
um
and we now have
69 percent of the recall vote
saying keep gavin newsom
a 38.8
point
lead
for keeping gavin newsom
people are coming in out of nowhere
i can see the energy in the audience
we have just reached a record for today
of
17 000 live viewers across our three
platforms
super chats are dumping in
i can't uh thank people enough who have
been using the coupon code no recall on
my website
look at these folks nicole irwin just
grabbed a membership tucker
freestone
joan perry has signed up eileen gaines
it is crazy what is happening right now
folks
this is a humiliating defeat for
trumpian republicans aligned with larry
elder
let's see what the copium is looking
like here at larry elder's headquarters
39
a gallon we dropped a penny way to go uh
that's outrageous and a lot of that has
to do with the amount of tax that's
tacked on each gallon of gas yeah
absolutely it's getting to be um
i paid six dollars the other day and
how does anybody
uh lisa rodriguez get yourself some
solar panels and get yourself an
electric car and get off the gas instead
of complaining about the gas prices
please
because are they pretending like it's
like it's not over are they actually
pretending like it's still going on in
gas a day so yeah it's absolutely crazy
and not to mention like the groceries
and
that's all groceries
of course have you guys seen the price
of mangoes lately fire season is almost
the uh the next season here that's a big
deal here in california is maine they
genuinely seem to be pretending like
this isn't over this is unbelievable
let's look at newsmax
so this is the whole the whole green
movement is not about preventing global
warming
isn't this the the fossil fuel dude who
shows up on everywhere and says fossil
fuels are great on nuclear i think
yesterday or today as well talking about
how no democrats support any kind of
nuclear it's the cleanest thing we got
as a you know in comparison except for
maybe you know like solar is very clean
as well obviously uh but nuclear is
incredibly clean it's incredibly
incredibly efficient and we can make it
safe and yet the big powers in the
democrat party are absolutely against it
do you have any idea why
yeah i have a i have a strong idea why
so first of all it's much cleaner than
solar if you look at the whole process
and it's by far the safest thing ever
created yeah and so there's this
question we can't afford not to be on
nuclear they seem to be pretending that
this isn't over now if you're just
joining us i do want to let you know
this lead has swelled more than nicki
minaj's cousin's brother's fiance's
apple bags because of supposedly the
code covered vaccine probably std or
kaitis could be
um this is now a 40.2
point lead for keeping governor newsom
i can't think of more humiliating
results
and at elder headquarters
they're talking about gas prices so
we're we're being suppressed with
everything that we have and they're
given
you know i don't think any of us are
against uh legal immigration we're all
for legal immigrant absolutely but we're
talking about the mass
migration of people coming across the
border that are unvetted we don't know
who they are we don't know what their
intentions are and we're seeing them not
just from like mexico but we're seeing
them from all over the world that they
come through central america up through
mexico into our states
very rarely oh my god are they clearing
out the are they taking the chairs away
it would be absolutely amazing
if the staff at the hilton
start clearing chairs out while this guy
still pretends it's not over that that
would actually be unbelievable
here is gun talk 101 with sarah
rodriguez let's break it down uh
rodriguez like is that like seagulls
what you can do and what perhaps the
progressive left wants to do
well basically you can't do anything
okay um you know thank god we have some
amazing sheriffs oh my god are they
being moved so they can clear the room
because it's over but they're not
admitting it's over that would be that
that would be the tops through each
county and we have some really really
really great shares that issue ccw so
thank god we do have a a carry state um
imagine if the lights turned off since
we're allowed to own um we have a crazy
weird list
and different laws that make it pretty
much impossible to to own anything
semi-automatic or
anything
you know with any kind of features
now i know in texas we just did
constitutional carry yes very very
exciting but meanwhile the numbers keep
rolling in uh they have shrunk a little
bit the lead has shrunk a little bit but
folks it is over this has been called
dave wasserman has gone to sleep
he's not he he went to bed okay um
i've seen enough the vote to recall
newsome has failed and subsequently
headed to bed good night when dave
wasserman is sleeping
it's over folks okay it is over and that
is that is absolutely it uh this has
failed and it has failed miserably
miserably
um oh they stopped the feed on the
screen behind oh yeah they cut the feed
so i think on this screen
i think they had
i think it was this feed
that they had on the screen back here or
a similar feed they seem to have cut it
they seem to have cut it
uh let's see how the reports are uh
coming in from nbc
thanks
a rural hospital in upstate new york
okay they are not talking about it
interesting
um the lead has again grown to 40.
wow what a lead we have 50 reporting and
it is over oh a big jump on 538 i'm
being told
where are the results
uh oh here we go
52 reporting 52 reporting and the lead
is now 42.
um
wow
this is this is
the the republican the guys this is a
partial referendum on trump larry elder
was pro-trump everything
um and the fact that this has failed so
miserably is a partial trump referendum
doesn't tell us about 22 okay
uh
but it is it is not a good sign
for uh trumpian lunacy certainly not
i appreciate everybody who keeps signing
up on my website i can't even keep up i
can't even keep up
i can't tell you how thrilled i am
that so many folks are watching today on
twitch i really appreciate that
um saturday i will be streaming the
second trump riots which hopefully won't
be riots hopefully it'll just be a very
very peaceful rally
uh but the reason they're gonna be there
is pretty violent they they are there in
defense of the rioters from january six
that's going to be on saturday i'm going
to be streaming that so i hope you'll be
here for that
make sure that you are following on
twitch or subscribed on youtube in order
to be notified about that
but today
just unbelievable numbers unbelievable
numbers especially after it looked for a
little while there i mean go back to the
polling right
the polling a month ago was
tied
it was tied
and these results just
stunning
so that is going to conclude my coverage
today
don't forget to follow don't forget to
subscribe don't forget to send me weird
tweets no but make sure you're following
me at on twitter at
um an incredible evening a humiliating
defeat for the republican party
dave wasserman has called it and i
believe that he is trustworthy on this
all right guys we will see you very very
soon
thank you for watching
good night